we had the Treasury Department just
announcing that african-american
abolitionist Harriet Tubman will be
replacing Andrew Jackson on the center
of a new $20 note she'll be the first
woman featured on US paper currency in
modern times of course Alexander
Hamilton will stay on the $10 bill I
mean it's kind of funny as we talk about
the transition to a paperless world of
foreign exchange that were so fixated on
who's actually on these dollar bills
well currencies are symbols of our past
and also our future it's a message that
you get every day when you look at
something they transmit values in this
case their values of abolitionism the
values of basically standing up when
everybody's asking you to be on your
knees and in something that is only a
positive message and they therefore this
is you know it's something you should
essentially cherish it's gonna it's
gonna be there for a long time around as
a currency analyst are you interested in
the actual physical appearance of the
currencies that you're analyzing
personally I love collecting currencies
and coins from all over the world
whether it's from France Greek Roman and
that Anna likes Russia Brazil pretty
much anything and it's it's it's just
fascinating from a it's essentially
gives you a sense of trust basically
that there's a unit of account that it
is basically used for exchanges but from
an investment point of view it is also
highly relevant because most of our
transactions by far are done on an on
paper basis but even you know the
physical act of paying for something is
very important people forget the
Manutius of it you can't pay your taxes
with one cent coins for example